hi so i'm shilotrata a second year
computational neuroscience phd student
at the donders institute in the
netherlands and today i want to talk to
you guys a little bit about truly
relaxing because i was replacing this
statistics professor the other week at
this beautiful place called corsendong
in belgium and whilst i was teaching
there i sat across from this
psychiatrist during dinner and he told
me that when he's really stressed he has
the tendency to just go home and binge
watch a lot of netflix series and eat a
lot of junk food and we kind of came on
the concept of truly relaxing versus
just coping with stress so today i want
to talk you through our conversation and
give you three things that i learned
about how to truly relax versus just
coping with stress so hopefully you
learned something and let's get straight
into it
so i think one of the first things you
have to do if you are struggling a
little bit with stress is to identify
what truly relaxes you so when i think
of truly relaxing for example i think of
buying books and reading books those are
two different hobbies by the way or i
think of really going back to my body
and like doing exercise for example
whereas when i think of coping with
stress it's more like sitting on the
couch and
binge watching netflix and i think
usually when we're at the point that
we're really stressed it's already a
little bit too late to truly identify
what relaxes us
so i would try to write down what
relaxes you before you are already at
the breaking point of stress because i
think at that point it's already a
little bit too late so if you have some
time right now just write down three
things that really relax you and you can
also put it down in the comments below
because i would love to read
how other people truly wind down so the
second thing is to do it when you are
not stressed yet so maybe you recognize
this that when you have a really busy
exam week and you're super stressed you
can think of a thousand things to do but
as soon as the exam is over you're kind
of left in this empty place of
what did i want to do with my life so i
think it's good to think about the
things that relax you when you are in a
very relaxed moment and one of the
things that i've really learned is when
you feel a stressful moment coming it's
kind of good to already imagine this
stressful moment and kind of work
yourself through it so imagine yourself
at that stressful presentation how you
will feel how your body will feel and
also what you will do after to calm down
because i think we can already mentally
prepare ourselves for quite stressful
moments if we go to this mental exercise
of seeing the stressful moment and also
seeing how you will cope with it and
then the last thing i want to give as
advice is to think of peak stress
moments and peak rest moments so i think
throughout the year we usually plan for
really stressful activities so we plan
all of those in but we don't really plan
in really truly restful weeks and i
think this is something i've learned
that it is really important so for
example i would try to every three
months three months for me works really
well but maybe you need it a little bit
more or a little bit less but every
three months to plan in a longer period
where you're truly resting and for me
that's like deconnecting from my work
deconnecting from the internet my
computer and usually going back into
nature with a couple of friends so i
love going to the forest for example or
rivers they are just environments that
truly inspire and relax me and i also
love being in bookstores all day and
like just reading different authors and
getting new information that's not
necessarily related to my field but i
try to in my year about every three
months to really plan in a longer period
so a week or at least a weekend to truly
let go of some of the stressors from
daily life and i would call this a
versus deep work i would kind of call it
deep rest so yeah these are just some
short tips that i learned on deep
breaths versus like a shallow rest i
would almost call it
let me know what you think and i'm
really curious about your experience and
how you truly deeply rest or get over a
stressful period so put it down in the
comments below
and otherwise see you next week bye